[Music]
[Applause]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the leia
heil pun
show it is of course powered by icon
plus capital the vc firm
definitely check them out on socials
they are absolutely brilliant ben
great to have you welcome to the show
how are you doing today
really great to be here um it's it's
great
just uh arrived in the office uh had had
a bit of a travel but it's
uh really great to have this this
conversation with you
yeah you've just flown in from miami
which is insane and we're gonna get um
all the information on your um i don't
know whether to call it secret meetings
it wasn't that secret um with the mayor
um but before we jump in just wanna let
everybody know that this
is sponsored by block fi so block fi you
can actually get i think it's around six
percent interest
on a couple different stable coins on
there um you can get 250
when you sign up so definitely would
recommend them um
but anyway ben welcome back you're in
romania right now
yeah definitely uh just just arrived uh
had some conversations with the team
and um excited for this conversation
yeah it's gonna be great um we were
trying earlier and i think your
community is so
vibrant what you've managed to build um
everybody is
so excited for this conversation they've
submitted a million and one questions so
i really hope that we're
able to get through them all but before
we do i do want to learn a little bit
more about
you um so how did you first get into
crypto i think that has to be the most
obvious question that everybody wants to
know
for sure um i would say and will always
say that the the lron community really
rocks
and we would not be here uh without them
so
um going a bit into the the questions
i initially stumbled into bitcoin
sometime in 2012
i believe um played with stuff and
it was 2013 that that i really went deep
down the rabbit hole
uh but i always asked um this
fundamental questions
i i was very fascinated in intrigued
by technologies that um would
essentially have the potential to
change the dynamics of humanity um so
they would be able to be put on the
scale of evolution
and uh bitcoin at that point was
extremely intriguing uh it had do two
properties
first it looked like a joke uh a lot of
people
like the serious people would not uh
look at at bitcoin would not understand
it
and then it looked extremely fascinating
because it was the first combination of
economics and technology in a way that
we've never seen before
now as as i studied things it became
clear that um one bitcoin
had this very um fascinating trajectory
for
for the future and what what it could
achieve but it also had some limitation
um as as i saw them then um
after that i i basically joined the nem
core team
after that i i started the fun to to
fund
some some projects that i thought would
solve some of the most
pressing problems in the space and then
um
after seeing that some problems were not
getting solved
at all uh we essentially gathered the
team
uh with which we can literally build
rockets and started working on
lron so um here's where we are now
so for those that don't know how would
you describe elrond in just
one sentence um with elrond
our goal is to build the backbone for a
high bandwidth low latency transparent
financial system
and secondly give access to this new
financial system to
anyone anywhere in the world okay so
a lot of people say that you guys are
similar or competitors to
ethereum and cardano do you agree
and if so how are you different and how
are you better that's
the most important question obviously
yeah i would push back a bit
on on this type of comparisons because i
i believe that people
uh very easily put all the projects in
some boxes
and and maybe for simplicity they they
always do that
but the idea with elrond is that we're
trying to
underscore what maybe most of the people
in the space forget
that um we're not here to compete
with um bitcoin with ethereum where
we're
we're not the killer uh ethereum killer
or bitcoin killer
but rather we are focused on bringing
the next billion people
in the space because we believe that if
we can bring
this large elephant um in the space
then uh we will be the wave that will
lift
all boats um in that sense bitcoin will
get
uh gain tremendously ethereum will be
able to gain tremendously
and even all the all the other projects
with which we
we essentially have a lot of
collaborations we'll be able to gain so
how we differentiate specifically
is that we've solved the uh performance
problem
for the blockchain space such that any
application that really wants to build
and embed blockchain into into their
architecture they can do it uh right now
not in the future with um elrond
and then secondly we're putting a lot of
focus into bringing a
user experience in the space that will
enable
anyone in the world to interact with
this technology without having them to
learn rocket science
um so this is the focus and and we
believe that
this is a non-zero-sum game um that is
we can collaborate with all these
interesting projects that really bring
value in a way that
we gain a lot and build a lot of value
but they also
also gain and it's this
where we see the largest opportunity for
the space
speaking of adoption um and
collaborations
obviously you were in miami and we saw
the picture of you with the mail which
is really really cool so
can you tell us what that meeting was
about
and what came from it
um sure so i'll give you a
an overview of that we always want to to
speak about
some matters when they essentially come
out
but i will say this miami
is at this point the epicenter
of the world in terms of technology
there's an
energy hunger and
focus there that you don't see anywhere
in the world
and it's absolutely fascinating to see
that you have a mayor like mayor francis
um a lot of really smart uh people
uh technical people founders and and so
forth and
people that are super hungry and i
cannot underscore
how important this is because they they
don't want to sit around and just have
discussions but they're focused on
building something
and they see this large opportunity and
then there's also
all this other opportunities with super
launch
large funds um other startups and and so
forth so
this is one of the things that we've um
seen
before it was super obvious this is why
in january
i i already was one time to miami to
have a conversation with mayor francis
and i remember that we were discussing
with the team that
there's a particular window in which
some mountains can be moved
you cannot do do this before not do this
after
and this is why um we believe that miami
will play a
key role in in elrond's future
um of course the maybe to give
some ideas um we see that there will be
a lot of startups there
right a lot of blockchain startups we
want to be present and offer them
some of the best tools and best support
they really need
um this is this is the gist of it i i
will definitely follow up with
more info as we finalize some things and
get them done yeah i mean i i know i get
that it's
you can't exactly announce things which
have just happened um but no definitely
appreciate that i think
you're you're right miami um the energy
there is truly unbelievable and it's so
refreshing to see a mayor
um pushing for that kind of innovation
um i'm london-based right now and um
our maya and the whole of london and the
whole of the uk to be honest
in my in the only way that i i can never
think to put it it needs a facelift
basically
um and it's so refreshing just to see
miami leading the way
um so that's really really cool now you
guys
um have the maya the maya am i am i
pronouncing that correctly the maya
exchange
yes mark so there are a lot of questions
that have come through
um about that so i'm just gonna grab
them here so
um okay so some people say that it looks
like the
um there's gonna be a delay for the
launch so can you talk to us about that
why is there a delay so the the idea
with the meyer exchange
is that um we've put a lot of thought
into bringing a dex a decentralized
exchange that will work on
lrand uh bringing it to the market in a
way where
this becomes not just another dex
but the key component that everyone will
use
in the elrond ecosystem and beyond um of
course
there's a tremendous effort to get this
done
and push it out it always seems like
this is just a small thing you get a few
things done
and then you have it out but it turns
out that the mara exchanges
is a monster uh it's uh extremely
important
that we have more than seven smart
contracts that
interact with a lot of critical
information
then we have front-end and we have apis
then we have
a lot of microservices that need to
interact and
i was just discussing with the team
before that
it seems like the days that we invest
right now
are almost each day at least one million
dollar
that we um essentially um
save out of the people's money with all
the hacks that we've seen
in the space it's like do you want to
spend
the days uh really focusing getting the
security
um super high or do you want to pay this
money
after you launch so it's that simple
and and we're super close um i would say
that
um we are pushing super hard so that
next week uh we have a launch with the
community
on the on the uh test net so that we we
can test this together and and so forth
we are super excited about that
but we also want to be very very um
aware
that this is an incentive for people to
hack
everything to hack the smart contracts
to hack the exchange
and we want to be very meticulous in
that respect
um and that being said uh the the
progress has been uh
tremendous um it always looks a lot
simpler
when you when you set out but then you
discover it's um
super large uh still as we get
very very close uh i believe that the
community will be
tremendously excited about this yeah i
mean i think they already are to be
honest because the majority of the
questions that came through were
um about the maya exchange and the
wallet um somebody actually asked if you
guys are thinking
um of creating a card and i think that's
a great question because
for me personally when i was getting
into the space i found the card
um exchanges which provide a card are so
powerful when it comes to adoption it
just makes it so much
easier um you know because sometimes it
can be such a headache
moving um your your crypto from a wallet
onto an exchange then into your bank
account
if it's all just in one ecosystem it's
such a smooth experience so
is there a card on its way for sure so
uh maybe to differentiate a bit we have
the miner exchange the meyer decks and
then the meyer application
the meyer application is this a very
very simple
uh perhaps the simplest ux in the space
and also
uh the most compelling and so in this
application
uh we currently have eagle we have
ethereum we have
binance and very very soon uh bitcoin i
saw that some people asked about this
uh in the in the thread you've got to
have bitcoin you just you can't not you
know
for sure for sure 100 and it's it's
super close
uh i was just discussing this with the
team um
i i think it will come uh probably in
the next one or two weeks
uh for sure and um the idea is that
with the meyer application we're trying
to provide this
very simple and compelling experience to
the space
and then within this of course you want
onboarding
fiat fiat on rams fiat off-ramps and a
card
if you can have this you you basically
have extracted away the entire
complexity
and can really push forward uh the fiat
on ramp
we have um the fiat off-ramp um
it turns out again this is one thing
that as we discussed with
with some of the uh providers initially
it looks super simple
and then yeah there's a mountain of
legal discussions that you keep
having uh but still we're we're making
progress and
i i think we will have this it just is
essentially just a legal discussion so
on weekly basis we
keep having the same discussions on a
legal front
and then the card as well um it's just a
a legal part
that we have to get through that we're
making
uh progress on um and we will have the
card
um it just has not come as fast as we
we want it to come everything takes time
and i always say it can take time as
long as
it's worth it you know you don't want to
rush things and then you have
technical issues and things go wrong you
know
i think i think that's actually what
charles hoskinson actually says a lot of
the time
when when the cardano community sort of
complain about how long things take but
you know you don't
mess up no no no it's uh it's uh i think
we have a lot of
momentum we have a really great progress
uh
and some of these features are are
coming um
they will hopefully come during the next
few
months we're pushing and we understand
that the card will be tremendously
valuable for the community so we're
pushing as hard as possible
yeah absolutely okay so here's another
really interesting one um so somebody
has asked
when um will the us be able to purchase
eagle
through the maya wallet uh
yeah this is another great question
and we we've been pushing on this
for months now um it turns out that the
us
uh for some reason is especially about
legal discussions yeah so uh what
whatever
the other uh there was a funny
tweet at some point that paul graham put
out
and paul graham you you probably know
him from y combinator
said something like um there were
several countries or several
let's say continents gathering together
and discussing about innovation the u.s
said i'll bring the technology asia said
something else and then
europe said i'll bring the legislation
or something the legal part
but interestingly enough it seems like
this
is even uh quite the opposite like yeah
it seems like
everyone else is building and then in
the u.s 80 percent is
legal discussion and you you get to have
a lot of backlog
just because of this legal discussion so
the short version is again
we have some partners we're making
progress
but there's two two basic limitations
there limitations there
one is the legal part which we keep
going through and it's
it's basically almost done and then
there's
there seems to be a kind of almost
industry
bandwidth limitation at this point
especially for the us
where uh most of the projects see much
more demand
that they anticip than they anticipated
and we're trying to help them with the
integrations and and stuff like that
so us is the largest market we
understand that
and we're pushing super hard to make it
happen uh hopefully it comes out soon
yeah everybody that i speak to that's
trying to build or you know even if it's
on a personal level not just like on a
company level or whatever it is
um is always trying to break the us
market and it's a nightmare for those
who aren't american who
who you know don't have residency or
citizenship or whatever it is it's just
a nightmare um i mean i think it's even
a nightmare for americans to be honest
um
with the sec i would say oh really why
would you say so
like uh just ask yourself why no company
is putting the hq in the us even the us
startups are
located somewhere else to uh not have
this type of discussion so it's
a bit crazy on that front yeah no
actually i think
absolutely right um but here's another
really interesting interesting one
somebody has asked um would maya ever
become a messaging service
like whatsapp or signal or something
like that
um yes the the idea for
a messaging app is of course super
compelling
um and we've had a lot of discussions
around this
uh internally of course what it would
mean to to have a super dap
basically the the idea would be that you
of course have
money and everything related to money um
but then you
you have messaging on the internet and
then you have
browsing so if you could have something
like that
you basically have everything that
someone needs to do
and there are interesting and
successful applications that have done
this if you look at wechat
this is precisely uh what they've done
um it's just that we want to make sure
that we focus
on having the first version of elrond
exactly what we need uh the first
version of
mayar with some of the key applications
and then move forward to to adding new
services
in order to make it still super simple
for the user
um but messaging uh is definitely one of
the key applications that we'll see on
the
on the uh very near future
i think even 10 years ago it was um
there were rumors that that's what
facebook were trying to do
they were trying to be you know the
wechat of
the west or whatever it is so it's
definitely something which
people are trying to do i always
wondered why they weren't able to
achieve that
i guess this may be a lot
about ux so in the west the users are
not necessarily
used to having one application with 10
applications
inside and then in china they're used to
uh
wechat which basically has everything
you can browse the web
you can do messaging you can do payments
you can do all the other stuff so it's
much more
an element of what users really want
what they would get used to
and making this still a super compelling
applications
because it's easy to just put in stuff
and much more difficult to make it
still very usable not adding too much
complexity and and so forth
but uh yeah i i would say that we are
going to see a lot of explorations
in this respect we even encourage a lot
of people to to come and build something
like this on elrond
and uh yeah with mayar i i guess we'll
have some some interesting experiments
on that front as well
and speaking of um adoption globally um
we've got a cool question which is
what is the strategic plan for adoption
in africa
asia and then the us which you did touch
on
sure elrond is very very strategic
in this respect so we're trying to not
just do
stuff that everyone does but rather take
some specific elements where we know we
can
shine and and beat anyone in the market
where we can move at high speed and
then execute on that so what we are
focused
on right now is it's clear that we have
a huge advantage in europe
um europe is where the majority of the
community is
it's also clear that asia is super
huge as an opportunity but also very
very
idiosyncratic so the the the things that
would work in europe
do not necessarily work in the in in
asia
and then it's the same for the us the us
is
a huge market but once you go in
it takes a bit of time to really go in
and make sure that
um the the legal part is bulletproof
uh but once you do of course there's a
huge opportunity in the us as well so
i would say that europe is is pushing
really fast forward
uh during the next period asia will will
follow and then the us
uh as well um it's just that
the us will probably be pending the the
legal stuff and as soon as it is done
uh it will just seem like uh it happens
all of a sudden but it was uh years of
work in the
background as it usually is that sort of
reminds me of what people say on social
media when they say um
people look at you and think it was
overnight success or whatever it is and
you're just there trying to grinding
every day to make it happen
yeah just a few years just a few years
yeah not that hard just a few years of
blood sweat and tears basically to
break into those markets um so you you
did touch on this
um but we'll just we'll just go to back
to a second so
how soon will the decks be released
it's a bit more specific yeah what we
are focusing
and what we are pushing on is that um
during the
the second half of next week and i'm
always
mindful of how many things are popping
up and i'll usually discover uh
discovered
each day but we're pushing super hard at
end of next week sometime we can go out
with uh
the first version on the test net uh
we'll have a really cool
um community approach there uh where we
do some some um cool stuff whether it's
testing competitions and and so forth
just to make sure that
everything is working properly then
immediately after that
uh there will be the the official launch
but uh yeah this this is a huge
huge milestone for for elrond and this
is why we're pushing
um as hard as possible to get it out
and can you tell us about some of the um
d fight interactions that will be
available
on the maya app um yeah so the
meyer dex is sort of um
independent of the meyer app first but
what's
super cool about it is that you'll have
this
um unique user experience where through
the meyer wallet which is a mobile
wallet you'll be able to
interact with the meyer decks very
simply to
provide liquidity for different uh
farming options different
liquidity pools and then exchange
some tokens of course and at first
you'll you'll basically have three pools
so there will be an
an eagle pool a mex pool um
and and um essentially a usd
pool all paired with uh mar exchange
token
um and um yeah this this this
i suppose will evolve very fast so
immediately after we push this
out all the projects that have been
waiting for something like this
can list their tokens so this this will
keep a natural feedback loop
uh really fast kickstart but uh
yeah we want to take this out push it
out um
of course there's also the maya exchange
token
with the native token of the tags um
people are waiting of course for that
to claim their token be able to provide
liquidity
um so this this is what we're focusing
at this point
uh there's also borrowing and landing
that's coming at a later point
and we've discussed about the the mar
land function
um and some other tools um of course but
we
we take it one step at a time always one
step at a time so we're gonna move on
just
a little bit um and someone's asked um
can you elaborate on the partnership
with
oin and how be utilized um for the
upcoming maya exchange
uh so the idea there is that
we will issue um a token
um a stable coin that is eagle-backed
uh so how it will be used is of course
will have
a pair that will launch on the meyer
decks and people will be able to
exchange the token take it
use it in some other ecosystems uh but
the the meyer exchange can be seen as
this global liquidity pool
that we will gradually where we will
gradually put all the tokens that
exist within the lrand ecosystem and um
all the new even nfd elements
that that will come to the ecosystem
okay um so in a minute i do want to go
and do a live um ama
so i just want to let everybody to know
so if if there are any questions
that you feel haven't been answered yet
if there's anything else you feel
you really want to know please just put
them um in the live chat now
um and then i can scroll through and we
will
we'll ask all of your questions um but
before we
do um the live ama do you have one more
question which is actually really
interesting um
somebody asked would you ever look at
doing a collaboration between l runs and
apple
um because they are actually looking for
a crypto expert and
they say that the maya wallet would be
perfect
um for ios no i think
everyone is super excited to see um some
of the news
that came out uh last week i guess
uh that um apple was looking for someone
on the payment slash cryptocurrency side
it's awesome news
uh it's great to finally see them move
forward we would be
super happy to to have a conversation
and um
help them with that um and um
it's actually a bit surprising that
they've moved so slow
uh on that front so they they're uh
they're basically the slowest uh
in this respect uh we have interesting
conversations with some
some larger um or not larger but
super large players um that are moving
uh forward trying to experiment and and
there's
even one um element that that i
i'll briefly touch on which is we
announced a collaboration with
hall ride and audi and then um
there was a lot of excitement in the
community when audi
um started showing a bit of more
interest
uh with even the social media stuff and
and so forth interacting with the elrond
community
so um when you see this type of very
large players
starting to make the moves uh you know
that everyone else
will start to make a move because this
is a bit of um
at first it it's almost like a mexican
standoff and then it becomes an arms
race
when when the first state moves in then
it's a race
who is going to move in fast how much
time do we have and so forth
it's the same for the companies and
i guess during the next few months we
will
certainly see some larger players
again similar to tesla similar to to the
other
interesting ones making a move hopefully
not like tesla
uh but uh yeah yeah i'm still here let
me just hit my camera back on
there we go um yeah i mean apple
they have moved really slow but i think
what's really interesting is a lot of
people are saying we're going
head first into a bear market but i just
i don't feel that way
whatsoever there's too much bullish
sentiment going on
um you know apple talking about their
own crypto expert i mean
it feels positive to me yeah i i guess
people always default to this um like
to the simplest narrative they have in
the mind so
uh what's what's bearish what's bullish
uh what's the cycle
of course we have several cycles is this
cycle over
um what if we look historically what's
happening and so forth
but i i believe at this point um
it's much more important to understand
the fundamentals
and why this could be hugely different
because of course you have a lot of
cycles but
we have to understand and get reminded
that the cycles are
are based essentially on fundamentals if
you don't have fundamentals
then you're going to have a
re-encouraged market yeah
but if you have the fundamentals if you
can accommodate
millions and tens of millions and
hundreds of millions of users
everything changes uh at that point the
idea of the super cycle
um supersedes um the the normal stuff
and um i do believe that we're at that
point of course
this doesn't mean that you'll have
you'll not have volatility
you'll not have the normal crazy stuff
that you
normal crazy stuff that you you uh
usually have in the space but
fundamentals are
changing the game completely yeah and i
think
that is what's going to drive in my
opinion this
second part of this cycle this potential
super cycle
um all right so i'm going to head over
to the comments now so guys if there's
anything you feel
hasn't been answered if you have any
other questions please just throw them
in the comments now because i'm going to
go through them all and we're going to
actually do a live ama
okay so um a lot of people are asking
when coinbase listing
i i'd love to be able to give an answer
to that
uh of course we're doing as i said
everything within our
power to make sure that uh things are
clear on the legal front
that we can help even on on technical
aspects
whenever they're needed we do have
conversations with
with all the largest exchanges in the
world
and all i can say is that from our end
we're we're ready um just yeah
it's just that uh we we need to see them
ready as well
i understand what about nfts um on the
hour on blockchain
so nfts are already available on the
airborne blockchain
we actually introduced a standard
a new standard for nfds something like
the ethereum standards but
with with a few improvements where you
have um embedded
royalties and stuff like that that you
can configurate
and this is very very cool um
we know that there are several projects
that are already building
something on these standards but we are
also taking this proactively and
preparing
um a launch in the meyer application
with nfds so i'll probably
um have a much more concrete update as
soon as
uh the light at the end of the tunnel is
clear
um things look awesome um at this point
so we already have the
concepts the design we've went through
all of that
but uh we're now pushing super hard to
to
make it uh real and get this new feature
out for the users so uh we'll probably
be out
sometime after the the meyer decks
what about um a digital identity
um digital identity is this
feature that will
it's super tricky the the trickiness is
not
that you will not solve digital identity
it's very easy to
find a solution but the tricky uh part
is how do you get adoption there are one
uh digital identity solutions for um
different things on the web no one knows
about them they
they don't work because they cannot
scale
there is no incentive to to adopt them
so we've been thinking a lot about
digital identity
and how you could solve this in a way
where there's an incentive
for you to adopt it let's say you you
have something like the
elrond um hero tags which are this
dns uh functions where you have not only
eagled
um uh addresses but you have bitcoin
addresses ethereum addresses binance
addresses and and
many other tokens uh afterwards if this
becomes
super useful or useful enough then the
users
will start adopt this as a kind of
digital id
uh option but the digital id will be a
secondary feature
uh because they will always adopt it
just because it's super useful
and then you have this this is always
the tricky
part you you can get the product but if
you don't have the distribution
uh you essentially don't have a useful
product
and we might have something super cool
on the on the digital id part but
uh we'll we'll push on that when it's
ready
so there's somebody absolutely um asking
the same question over and over again in
the comments which i just
have to ask you um otherwise i won't be
able to see any of the other comments
so somebody asked who is ben's biggest
idol
idol idol yeah i do
i i would say that there are a few
people from which i
i've learned um a huge deal um
at some point when when i thought
my question was always um
who have been the the most let's say
influential relevant or important people
that have
have lived this is a rather easy
question
you study a bit you see them and so
forth but then the more
interesting question is who are those
people uh today uh that that most people
don't don't really see
that they're not yet the most uh famous
people but they're
really really good in what they're doing
if you can discover them
you can find um the most relevant things
in different subjects
at some point um i i believe it was 2012
or something like that i thought that i
i
at that point i discovered musk i
discovered feel
and discovered paul graham um
essentially devoured
everything they they wrote or thought
about
and and so forth and was extremely
fascinated
by what each of these individuals have
achieved and how they saw the world
because
at the fundamental level there was a new
way of seeing the world
each of them had um this view on
let's say program was was the grand
master in terms of startups
that there was no one like him peter
thiel was
was a really idiosyncratic
thinker in terms of technology startups
and
the future and then musk like he's crazy
of course
uh especially these days but there's
basically no one like him
in terms of um achieving uh what what he
sets out to so these are a few
really cool people that that i've
learned a tremendous amount from
elon musk is an interesting one because
so i share the same sentiment towards
him
um i think one man
going head to head with nasa gosh that
sounds like the beginning of like a
movie title doesn't it one man
goes head to head so i think it's
unbelievable
um and a lot of people hate what he's
done recently with
regards to bitcoin and and all that
stuff and i understand that
um but i still don't think you can knock
him for
what he's achieved i mean it's just
insane um
sure sure no he he does have
some things to learn uh in terms of
crypto and blockchain um
i i suspect uh that he has a grand plan
for for this part as well yeah there
have been some cool threads
um but uh yeah i would not throw
everything he's done
in the in the trash just because uh some
things
seems uh seems crazy um
it will be tricky for him um of course
like if he continues this
um at some point he it will it could
backfire so uh i guess
yeah he is testing the limits at this
point
uh i i would not want to to be uh
yeah in that position where uh
everything is on the line
because i i tweet two three things and
then things start burning up
oh yeah absolutely i think he has a
bigger plan
um and we're yet to see what comes of it
um but of course back to you guys
um so launch pad i'm getting i'm getting
when launch pad that's what's coming
through here on the questions
again we have some uh
projects there uh we pushed a lot um
they're tremendously valuable we're
super super excited about them
there have been some some legal um
discussions again
uh legal seems to be this thread that uh
keems
keeps reappearing in in some of the
things uh
but we are now uh very very close to
having some updates on that front as
well
um on those legal issues can you tell us
anything else
um i know somebody was wondering what
are the legal issues that you have when
it comes to the us
no so it's not legal issues it's just
that we're trying to
approach things proactively to make sure
that we're bulletproof that whenever
there's a discussion we have
10 steps ahead make the plan can
provide the the details and at this
point the the legal part
uh with respect to launch but projects
is just
trying to help them prepare to to be
ready
and uh when they move forward to to have
things ready so that
um they're they've done their homework
and and so forth so someone's asking is
this a paid interview so i do want to
just make this really clear this isn't
paid this isn't sponsored
um i actually just reached out to ben
because um i was interested in
errands and i wanted to just learn more
about the community so yeah this
absolutely isn't paid
um everybody knows i'm always honest
when something is paid
i'm powered by icon plus capital and my
little sponsors are there in the corner
blocked by luno so yeah this isn't this
isn't sponsored at all
um so we're getting questions through
about marketing
why haven't you guys started marketing
which actually basically proves that
this isn't paid because this isn't a
marketing thing
whatsoever sure uh
so the idea is that we're in a very very
special position at this point
we now have the tools to really build
anything on top of a blockchain
um and we've prepared some of the last
elements that we really need
for the projects to not only come in and
play with the technology
but have what they need to build it have
what they need to
launch their tokens create their
economies
build their communities and push things
to the next level
and during the next period we'll have a
very
very very significant push on this front
just to
uh bring everyone that has been building
on elrond
um help them get out there have them uh
make the progress and and um launch
their entire ecosystems uh this will be
the
the most interesting theme that that
will follow
and just going back to the the decks
we're getting some questions through i
know you said it's not about comparing
but i guess
there are so many different options in
this space now as
things start to grow and really expand
so what would you say the difference is
between um the maya decks and then
something like pancake swap or uni swap
sure uh i i would say that there are a
few elements that really count
um and would bring us to a point where
if you take a look at especially uni
swap
and and some of these other options uh
there have been a very
very limited number of users that have
been able to access this
either due to the the large fees and
problems that we've seen
or due to the complexity and
it's here that we want to make a huge
leap forward both that this becomes
super inexpensive and that you can focus
on on testing some of these elements
getting new features out and and so
forth but then also
ux wise enabling a super large amount of
users
to uh be part of this and be part from
day one
is something that none of this
ecosystems had
and we're very very curious to actually
see how the elrond community
adopts and plays with these tools as
they come out
so i'm reading that there's been some
fun i personally don't know enough about
this
so um i'm getting could you please ask
um the big wallets so hang on let's have
a look okay so coin bureau basically are
putting out some funds about
big wallets and centralization i
actually did read about this
um so apparently the majority of the
supply is centralized so talk to us
about that
yeah no this is this is actually just a
simple matter
uh we've basically discussed and the
entire community knows this
the top 10 wallets are basically
exchange wallets
this is this is uh not only for elrond
but on every blockchain
when you have binance when you have all
the other large exchanges
you have large wallets that are the the
uh
cold and hot wallets of the exchanges
since the community knows this
there's basically not too much to to
discuss around it
uh we will do something um that's
still proactive and helps diffuse
any type of steam on on this level
uh we'll try to add some cool labels on
the explorer
that just gives you an idea this is the
binance wallet this is the bitfenix
wallet and and so forth
and by doing so um we're trying to
both anticipate and proactively defuse
um
any type of discussion related to this
we actually
um i would say are are at the point
where
there are very very few networks that
are
as decentralized and then scalable
as as lron we have a very large number
of nodes
um more than 3 200 number of nodes that
are active in the network
more than 45 staking providers um
and then all the all the metrics uh
around
adoption are also very very uh
interesting so i i always appreciate
the the ball when it's raised
and will will try to score some some
goals with that
so uh not nothing to to uh
worry about it's it's just the normal
elements and
um i guess there have actually been some
some comments from the community where
um
someone clarifies what each of the uh
accounts is is doing who it belongs to
and and so forth yeah i have seen that
in the comments um
so there we go um so no i think
everybody really appreciated it i'm just
reading through now everyone says that's
great we're getting some
um we're getting some answers we
couldn't get anywhere else so that's
great that's always the goal
um okay so just lastly then because
we're coming up to an hour 45 minutes
um what's the entire 10-year
plan what can we expect
yeah so this is uh the one element where
we
think very very deeply about in addition
to the immediate part and as i said
uh we believe that this is a
multi-trillion dollar
opportunity a generational opportunity
that is
unprecedented and
i i don't think we've seen any
opportunity that is
as large and as significant as this
since the invention of the internet and
this will have
implications for for countries um
in the of the world for for uh
banks for institutions funds and and
startups and so forth so um
we actually coined this term uh of uh
the the era of autonomous banking
and we believe that this is what's going
to happen we're going to have a kind of
100 trillion opportunity where states
are going to adopt blockchain technology
as a
as a settlement layer banks the the
smartest ones
will proactively try to um race
uh in a way where they adopt this
technology then um startups are going to
build on it and
what elrond specifically is going to do
is
going back to what i've mentioned right
at the beginning
create the backbone for this high
bandwidth low latency
global and transparent digital economy
then give anyone anywhere easy access
through the meyer wallet
by connecting these two elements you you
first have
internet like performance for the
blockchain so
almost instant super inexpensive and
global
and then by interacting with all this
technology
in a wallet apple like with apple like
experience
um you you basically are in a different
world you
at that point you can see how you can
make all the payments just
from one wallet um can have new uh use
cases for artists
where it's nfps and stuff like that um
but you you also have essentially a
fundamentally yeah significantly
improved economy it's like right now
your
the entire economy is working uh with a
very very slow feedback loop
so from you you have to wait 24 hours
until you make some transfers and they
settle
and and so forth imagine what it would
mean to have this instant settlement
layer
for the global economy um at that point
you're you're
at a different level ben i want to thank
you so much it's been so brilliant um i
think
you know just so everybody knows none of
the questions that we asked
um initially were were given so i think
it's really brilliant just to be able to
you know address
concerns and worries and fud and
whatever it is just on the spot i think
it really puts faith into the community
so it's really important um
so yeah i want to thank you so much for
joining it's been absolutely great ben
um really great to be here i i think um
it's probably the best time to be alive
uh we're super focused on the super
focus on the next steps and uh just
focus on
making progress forward so thank you
very much
yeah absolute pleasure and guys and
please don't forget to hit the subscribe
button on my youtube channel um i'm
always going to be talking to
um really brilliant guests in the
community um and just spreading as much
education awareness and adoption as
possible um
because yeah like ben says it's such a
brilliant time to be alive right now and
we're so lucky to be
um right at the beginning of all of this
because i think it's just going to be
bigger than
then we know so there you go um ben
thank you so much
thank you everybody for watching um for
tuning in and please don't forget to
subscribe
so you never miss a guest we will see
you all next week bye bye